-Welcome back, everybody.
One of our writers, Karen Chee
is 25 years old.
So every now and then,
we like to see exactly how muc
she knows about the past.
So it's time once again
for a segment we call
"What Does Karen Know?"
♪♪♪♪
Hi, Karen.
-Hi. How are you?
-I'm good. I miss you very much.
I hope you're feeling
healthy and safe.
-I am, thank you.
I miss you too.
Are you also healthy?
-I am healthy and I am safe.
And I'm very excited to see if
you know some of these thing
from the past
that I remember very well,
but you might not have
any frame of reference for
So I'm just going throw up
the first picture.
Karen, do you know who this is
-Um, no.
But they just look --
Are they famous?
They just look like
normal people.
-You'd think. You'd think.
But they are --
Well, I should say
for a very brief period of time,
they were super famous.
What do you think
they were famous for?
-Are they a band?
-Yes, they are a band.
-They were famous --
They are the people
who invented the Rachel,
the haircut in the '90s?
-No, no,
but around the same time.
They had one very famous song,
and I'm going to give you
the beginning of the title
Mmm.
-Okay.
-Mmm.
-They're brothers.
Would it help if I told yo
they're brothers?
-Um, no.
Is the title something
I would know?
-It's "MMMBop."
-Oh, no.
[ Laughs ]
-Okay, Karen, you're looking a
a band called Hanson.
And Hanson were brothers.
And they had
a song called "MMMBop,"
which very strangely was about
if I remember correctly,
sort of lost love, despite
the fact that they were all,
I don't know, like 12 years ol
maybe and younger.
But it was --
They were a big deal.
Alright, you're 0 for 1, Karen
-That's too bad.
They were so sad, so young
-Yeah.
They seem very happy
in the song,
but the lyrics
didn't quite match.
Anyways, it's an upbeat song
And I think we could
all "MMMBop" our way
through this quarantine.
Alright, moving on.
Karen, here's your next photo.
Do you know who that is?
-Oh, God.
No. Oh, my God.
Like a Halloween figure?
-That is the Crypt Keeper.
The Crypt Keeper was the host of
a television show,
a horror anthology show called
"Tales from the Crypt"
that was on HBO, I believe
-Okay.
-And you know what?
He had a sense of humor,
the Crypt Keeper.
And he wasn't quite as scary
as you thought.
He liked a good pun.
And all things considered,
I think,
if you could get by his looks,
the two of you would probabl
get along pretty well.
-Oh, that's a little bit mean.
Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you.
-Oh, no, you fully judged a book
by its cover
and I just expect
more from your generation.
-Yeah, I looked at it
and I was like,
"I don't want to be
friends with that."
-You'd really like him.
Here's another historical figure
of great note.
Do you know who that is, Karen
-No.
But it looks like
he's in trouble.
-He is on the stand, but this is
after the trouble.
His name was John Bobbitt.
Do you know who that is?
-No, I don't think so.
John Bobbitt?
-He and his wife
had some marital trouble.
It's hard to explain.
Sometimes when a man and woman
love each other very much
and they have a fight --
You know what?
I think it's maybe better --
Why don't you later
just Google the Bobbitts?
-Okay. Is there a murder?
-No. Everybody -- insanely
everybody -- everybody is okay
Alright. You did fairly well
Fairly well, Karen.
-Yeah, thank you.
Now I have photos
that I'm going to show you
that you haven't seen before
-Okay.
-Do you know who this is?
-I don't know who that is.
I don't have any --
I mean, it could --
I mean, it looks like --
you know, like it's sprung fro
the artistic tree of "Cathy,
but that's --
that's not who that is.
-No. I don't know what that --
Okay.
So basically what this is, is --
it's Lizzie McGuire.
It's the cartoon version o
Lizzie McGuire.
-Gotcha. And Lizzie McGuir
was played by...?
-Hilary Duff.
-Oh, okay. That makes sense.
Alright, 0 for 1.
-Okay. Yeah. That's okay.
Solid zero percent.
Okay, do you know who this is?
-Well, it's -- it's obviousl
a baseball video game.
But it's definitely --
Why is it different?
'Cause it does seem like not
a hyper-realistic baseball game.
-No. It's a perfect game.
It's called "Backyard Baseball."
And it was part of the serie
called Backyard Sports.
And it was a computer game -
and it's like the best game.
The character you see righ
there is called Pablo Sanchez.
And he's, like, the G.O.A.T.
He is so good at every sport
and you always want him
on your team.
-And what computer system
would you play it on?
-I think we had,
like, this large gray PC.
And I always had computer time
30 minutes a week,
so I would get to pick which
half hour of the week I wanted
And I would sit down
and use the computer.
-That's fantastic.
I think in quarantine rules,
parents are giving their kid
a full 30 hours a week.
-Okay.
So we know this actress
is Elaine Hendrix
and she's legendary, but do yo
know what role she's playing
-Is that like from "Gossip Girl"
or something?
-No!
It's from "The Parent Trap."
-Oh. So that's the Lindsay Lohan
version?
-Yeah.
It's the best "Parent Trap."
I have not seen the older on
and I don't care for it.
-[ Laughs ]
Alright. Well, obviously, we'r
trying to find things to watch
I will try very hard to find
time for this new "Parent Trap."
-[ Laughing ]
It's not new anymore.
It's very old.
It's very good.
-Alright. Still,
it's not my "Parent Trap."
Give it up for Karen Chee,
everybody.
This has been
"What Does Karen Know?"